Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for mines.
You,
Hey,
February 26 2018 how's it going?
How,
Oh yeah.
Are you enjoying your February of 2018?
Well,
you should cause you never know.
You never know if there's going to be another February of 2018 nothing is
promised.
Just remember to look up at the clouds today and smile.
Okay,
sorry.
Um,
I'm threatening to get on Instagram once again and I'm going to get on there and
I'm going to be come as someone who's in the public eye that inspires you.
So I just want to try out some of my inspiring words,
you know,
uh,
my,
my wife,
my laugh,
she's on Instagram and I always look at those things.
It always cracks me up.
People sit there,
they act like they're trying to inspire you and it's really just an excuse.
So they can take their shirt off and show you like how great a shape Darren.
Okay.
Always set goals beyond your own belief in yourself.
Because even if you fall short,
you're still in the money round,
whatever the fire king of a finish up.
You know what I mean?
Then they're just sitting there with like fucking eight pack abs,
you know,
but like with a hat on,
like a fucking knitted hat,
it's like,
dude,
I thought your cold when you put a shirt on him.
All right.
He starts off being conti and it's only gonna get mocked country from there.
So I was out in,
um,
I was out in Santa Monica and I was coming back towards Hollywood,
you know,
to get my,
uh,
my botox injections.
Um,
a lot of people don't know that about myself that I am actually,
yeah,
I've lied to you all of these years.
I'm actually 63 years old and um,
I take a very high quality botox injection every,
uh,
every third day,
sorta like the patrones silver of like botox,
you know,
I don't know shit about to Keel.
I'm sure somebody is going to say,
oh,
actually this Cleveland mid range to Qi Lu,
you move,
would you move the Goodie?
No one cares.
No one cares about you.
And your fucking Tequila connoisseuring so anyways,
so I'm driving into Hollywood,
right?
Um,
and uh,
I stopped at a red light and there's all these,
these pro second amendment people standing there,
right.
What's like megaphones and shit and they just keep you out on it.
Oh,
whoa.
Right.
Like literally some of the dumbest fucking people I've ever seen in my life.
Uh,
and that my friend is what always now,
now,
now if I was a moron,
which I am.
MMM.
I would look at those people would be like,
yes,
that's what people who defend the second amendment look like.
Rather than being like now people who fucking are going to stand at a fucking
red light with a bull horn,
there's a certain level of intellect that that's going to have.
And there it is.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like when like the left goes out and they protest something.
Like remember that I always bring this shoe,
that checkup,
who fucking sat there when Trump was getting a sworn and she has good,
yeah,
that fucking
like what sort of balanced conversation could you have with a human being?
Like that.
And it's just saying like these Blm,
I just,
it was fucking hilarious.
And then people were beeping at them.
Yeah.
I don't,
you can't tell when someone hits so horn,
whether it's they don't have like the,
uh,
the positive beeping.
I guess that's like a peep.
You can't tell if they were beeping,
like,
yeah,
keep yelling that shit.
That doesn't make any sense.
I don't understand America.
Love it or leave it.
So if you want to,
uh,
adjust anything,
then you need to get the fuck outta here.
Like,
it's just like,
I mean,
that's what the flyers did for the last fucking 40 years and that's why they
have yet to win another cup because whatever they did,
the 74 and 75,
they continued to fucking do up until about maybe six or seven seasons ago,
you know?
Oh,
we're just going to beat the shit out of people.
Right.
That worked in [inaudible] 74 and 75 before social media,
before millennials were even born.
You could do that.
All right.
And they didn't adjust and look at them now.
Couplets.
They won the Stanley Cup since Gerald Ford was an office.
And that's fucking unbelievable,
right?
Actually it really isn't.
When you look at it is there is 30 teams.
If you win one once every 30 years,
that's pretty much average.
So they're a little behind the little behind the curve.
They need to stay off the class,
get a little extra help on how to cycle it around.
MMM.
Yeah.
And I love how they did and they go,
those,
these fucking morons are going to love it or leave it.
And what the defending was an amendment to the constitution,
which is a change.
Okay.
Fucking unbelievable.
And the look on their face too,
when they were pissing people off because like these fucking morons,
we're actually looking at him getting mad.
I actually rolled my window down because I want to call one of the guys fat.
I just looked at it like this is,
this is going to be,
how mad can I make this guy?
It's so childish.
But that's how it kind of looked at it.
But,
um,
yeah,
I,
they th the look on their faces of them just pissing people off.
They had total joy in their faces.
So it's just like,
you're not making it any better.
You're actually making it worse.
I Dunno.
Why can't people just,
just sit down and just be like,
like,
you know,
the people are the defendant ar 15,
look man,
I fuck fucking spoon and shot myself in the Far East.
And then the people on the left can be like,
excuse me,
a set up butterfly.
We're just saying that maybe a shitty little about difficulty,
one of,
um,
maybe that's what we need to do.
Maybe.
Maybe that's a way that each side can hear each other,
each side performed as a stereotype,
you know,
or wait,
maybe you present your liberal opinion.
Okay.
And your,
your,
your viewpoint of what you think the right sounds like.
You know,
I real raise my daughter gender neutral.
Right.
And then they have to my neighbor a few,
they had to be like,
do fucking liberal snowflake.
Um,
anyways,
I've,
oh my God,
I've never gotten more goddamn responses.
So when you start bringing up fucking guns,
um,
just gotta be,
how can you do it?
Like,
you know,
you gotta let these fucking people still have their machine guns so they can get
out there and then four wheelers or you know,
who,
who knows,
who knows what's going to happen.
I am curious too,
as far as,
um,
uh,
well before I finished it,
how,
how do you figure out who's a fucking lunatic and who is it?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Because I haven't done any research on this,
but I would be willing to bet that at least 98% of registered gun owners are
fucking responsible.
You know,
they're out there shooting squirrels off their balconies.
Right?
What that gun you can you see at the end of Scarface?
So whatever the fuck it is,
I don't know.
It gives a shit.
That's all they're doing.
Jazz,
the fucking Squirrel,
man.
God Damn cute racks as far as I'm concerned.
Good eight.
No,
it's good.
And it's like a game of chicken for the little bit of a captain crunch in it.
Um,
it's gotta be a way to a dean off,
you know what I mean?
I don't think anybody who owns a gun thinks that some fucking lunatic should get
a gun like that.
So why don't we just work on,
okay.
Uh,
we'll work on that.
How would you do,
how would you possibly fucking do that?
I Dunno.
Okay.
I actually got into it with somebody,
you know,
they were trying to tell me that silencers were legal in New York and I'm like,
dude,
they're not.
He's like,
yes they are.
And I said,
dude,
I lived at,
they're not,
and then he like,
immediately he goes,
they are,
you just have to register.
So then I Google it and it says that suppressors are legal in like some like 42
different states.
And one of the states they weren't legal in was New York.
And then the guy gets his rather than being like,
oh,
okay,
I'm wrong.
He gets like fucking mad.
And he goes,
well,
is that a new law?
It's like now,
I dunno.
I Dunno when it came from far as I know,
whenever I fucking live there,
you can't have a silencer and fucking New York City.
That basically means that I'm going to go assassinate.
It's not like we have a bunch of fucking coyotes and shit running around
alligators and that top shit because in Florida they would just like,
well you know,
cause we shot guns with silences in Florida.
They would just go and we were laughing at first.
He said,
yeah,
having a salad suit in New York means I basically want to kill somebody and I
don't want anybody to hear it.
And they laughed.
And down here they were like,
oh that just down here,
that just means there's an alligator on your yard and you don't want to wake up
your neighbor,
you know?
So it's like,
oh,
all right,
I get it.
Plus my ears a junk.
I think if I had a fucking gun,
I would,
I wouldn't want to have a,
a suppressor,
you know?
I mean,
that's gotta be,
it's gotta be the best.
If somebody breaks into your house,
all right and your gun is readily available and you have a suppressor on it,
right?
And you just fucking stand up and your jam jam scratching your ass and you just
clean that up in the morning.
He just go right back to bed,
you know,
and you just lay in there,
you did something fucked up the night before.
You're not,
you know how you wake up.
Well,
you don't just sort of gradually wake up.
You fucking eyes just come open.
I just don't fucking shoots there.
I have to shoot somebody to watch that.
Ah,
God damn it.
The bloods all dry them a floor plan.
Um,
anyways,
I find the whole fucking thing fascinating.
I also find it fascinating that it,
you know,
as much as I'm a believer that you shouldn't,
uh,
the government shouldn't be the only one that has guns.
It's like too much powers considering what the fuck they're doing.
Uh,
I also don't,
I think we're,
as far as technology goes in owner of media,
I just don't think that a bunch of people with like guns in their houses is
going to stop any sort of fucking,
you know,
if we went,
I don't know how much crazy where could get in this country,
but if we really went totally fucking crazy,
I really don't think a bunch of armed citizens who are not organized or even
remotely have the training or the weaponry of what the,
you know,
the martial law,
whatever the fuck would be enacted,
would it even be able to stop it?
You know?
And then the people that took over in power would also control the media and
then they would,
they would,
um,
put out information to make those patriotic citizens look like they were fucking
Nazis and the whole thing would fall apart.
Um,
however,
you know,
for a lot of people,
I think it would be a fun way to go out.
You want my guns come and kill them going get them.
Do you want my soul cycle?
Well,
I'm going to put it up on craigslist next week.
Um,
all right,
let's get out of this fucking topic.
We'll talk about it later.
I'm trying to be even here,
like sort of trashing both sides and seeing both sides.
You know,
this is my Instagram inspirational thing on gun control.
I'm trying to see both sides of this.
In the end of this I will take my shirt off.
It's not even that people in the public.
I do that.
It's the people that follow them.
I guess if they are inspiring them,
I guess they are doing something,
but it is just so clearly,
it has nothing to do.
Even if they inspires somebody that's even more for that person that took their
shirt off to fucking feed their ego.
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
or maybe I just never looked good with my shirt off in shape.
Errata shape because I was so pasty white,
you know,
I felt bad for fucking,
there was,
this is a fellow celebrity or red head and he had his shirt off on a boat and
everyone was,
you know,
and he's in great shape and that's all everybody talked about was how fucking
Whitey was.
You know,
if redheads ever had a bodybuilding contest,
what it would,
basically they would do it for the blind.
The blind would just come up like touching their torso and be like,
okay,
you could be,
this could be a little more defined,
you know?
Then we'd sit there with her angry freckled fingers,
you know,
giving them the finger.
Maybe.
I have no idea.
All I know is that,
uh,
since I've become a dad,
I've,
I,
you know,
I don't have time to fucking watch games the way I used to,
especially like hockey and basketball,
how,
how many games there are and all that.
Every time I fucking start to get caught up on the Bruins,
I look at my little thing and it says,
you have five new games to watch.
And I know they're playing great and they're making all these moves.
I don't know if this trade went through,
but we got fucking Rick Nash from the Rangers and I was thinking,
Oh God,
like who the fuck did we give up for this guy?
And,
uh,
we gave up a first round draft pick.
Who the hell is it here?
And we gave up,
uh,
we gave up Ryan Spooner and Matt Volesky.
Uh,
I don't know.
Rick Nash is 33.
I loved Ryan's phone.
Um,
ah,
well what are you going to do?
Where are you going to do it?
But I,
I'd say,
Oh,
who knows?
I like what Sweeney's don't,
he's just like,
all right,
fuck it.
We're,
we're like right there.
Let's push this over the top.
It gives us a physical presence.
A guy that gives you 30 calls to say,
should I take the approach,
Jeff?
We got better.
They're going to put them on the
second line with David Cray.
Gee,
now you got Bershee Rod.
Yeah.
You got Pasternak,
Eh,
you got,
you got Marshawn and the first slide,
okay.
That gives us two really solid lines
and I haven't watched that many games issues,
but the game at games I'd been watching,
our fourth line actually kinda contributes quite a bit.
Um,
we're young,
we're fast now.
We got this guy and he's a,
he's a big presence out there.
He doesn't really drop the gloves,
but I mean that's combined completely taken out of the game.
By the way,
people who always talk about how much they love Olympic hockey and if they could
just get the fighting of the NHL that they would actually sit down and watch it.
While all I want to say is fuck you,
you lie and cons because you ruined the game that I loved because they've pretty
much got fighting out of the game.
Certainly in the playoffs you get in the playoffs,
the goons are gone,
the goons go home,
all the goes go home at night,
the goats go home at night,
they go home and during the fucking playoffs plas you send them all home.
And every year I get a little sad.
You know when I see that,
and I think back to the eighties when the fucking Bruins played the,
the fucking buffalo Sabres and it was standing room only in the penalty box.
It's like two guys sitting down.
Three people standing up behind them look like they were stuck in an elevator
back then.
That was called setting the tone.
That's not what happens anymore.
Is it
all these people out there trying to take away my guns and my four whalers,
sorry.
Oh,
he's people out there trying to take my gun and my four wheeler.
You fucking liberal snowflake.
I don't,
you just skip to some socialist country.
Well,
we have a teddy sharpie.
There is no room for violence seeing hockey.
It just shows ignorance.
Um,
okay.
That's what I'm gonna do from here on out.
Whenever I present the liberal side,
I'm going to try to do,
I'm going to do a fucking,
I need another good liberal argument.
You know what I mean?
I don't know why the fuck we just don't switch over to solar power.
All these stupid fucking rednecks role in Cole.
I should have solar power.
So he's fucking oil companies and corporations.
They don't want to do it.
Um,
America love it or leave it or adjusted,
you know,
as eight as everything does.
Everything in the world does.
As it moves forward,
it adjust,
you know,
as virus adjust,
adjust,
I should say,
I adjust,
adjust who we're all using that hand sanitizer and all that shit.
You know.
What are the viruses doing?
Going well,
I guess that's it for us.
I guess.
We can't kill any bought people.
They're not,
they're hitting the gym that drinking that shit up and they get an even stronger
and there's,
uh,
there's,
there's going to be a fucking look at,
look how strong the flu is.
So cut me.
Fucking kids died.
They should terrify everything adjusts.
All right.
You can adjust fucking,
you know,
amendments are adjustments to the constitution.
Get Dumb fucks over there.
Um,
and I'm not saying,
I'm not saying you shouldn't defend your car.
I'm going to be liberal here.
I'm not saying she wouldn't defend your gun.
I'm just saying some adjustments maybe need to be made.
You know,
I don't remember.
I almost said Tom Sawyer.
Uh,
who's the guy who said the British should come or Paul Revere?
I don't remember his kid going into a log cabin,
you know,
shooting it up with a musket.
All right.
Uh,
what do we got here?
Hand sanitizer.
Super Virus.
Super,
super,
super.
You guys remember the Super Fun and when that came up to your cable station,
I have to,
I have the worst fucking Goddamn Internet.
He has the worst fucking Internet in the world.
Bup,
bup,
Ba.
Okay,
fact or fiction
can hand sanitizer use,
create a super bug.
Hand sanitizer.
Dispensers are mounted everywhere in office buildings,
restaurants,
schools,
and hospitals.
In case you didn't know what everywhere meant,
we can carry bottles of it and our purses and on our key chains there,
we'd covered male and female behavior,
but we,
but are we using it correctly?
And Kenny use be used to make a super bug bug bug USA Today,
network reviews,
facts and fiction surrounding hand sanitizer
myths.
Kids who suck their thumbs shouldn't use hand sanitizer.
It's generally okay to apply hand sanitizer on a child.
Oh cheese that just covered themselves legally.
Generally it's okay.
My kid just died.
Well,
we didn't say totally a taste.
A taste amount from the hand.
There's not usually a problem.
Nicole,
we'd a registered nurse and a certified specialist in poison information told
USA Today network
at most.
There may be some irritation in the mouth from the alcohol based products.
Do keep an eye on kids though.
Fuck you.
Goddamn advertising.
There we go.
Um,
hand sanitizers often smells good and comes in bright colored packages that's
attractive to children.
Ingesting a large amount of but could make them very sick she said,
or shit faced depending on what brand you use.
Myth sort of myth,
sort of using hand sanitizer can use the create can lead to the creation of
super bugs.
The concern about Sukkot,
superbugs centers around a chemical ingredient found in many antibacterial
products called try.
CEO said try a sale.
Sad is not found in most hand sanitizers,
but it is found in many antibacteria hand soaps and cleaners.
Recent studies have found that the chemical may alter the way hormones work in
the body.
According to federal drug admin.
The FDA.
All right.
And may also contribute to bacterial resistance to antibiotics or superbugs.
Should I say [inaudible] is not considered an essential agree for many products
and its use is currently under review by the FDA and the environmental
protection agency.
The FDA is also made up of a bunch of people that used to work in the industries
that they're supposed to be policing.
So who knows.
All right,
this this morning I am a moron because there's a bunch of other facts.
I don't even know what the facts,
I just get bored.
But listen,
this is why I don't read a lot of Shit because I'm reading this on USA Today and
then USA today just has a bunch of
like clickbait
like underneath.
Remember Catherine Bell from Jag?
See where she is now.
Google may not show you this.
Enter any name.
This is on the USA does today site.
This is supposed to be like a fucking reputable newspaper.
Top five local solar companies.
Check out best and worst reviews.
I want solar panels.
Oh one one big one.
Right on my forehead.
Right.
Um,
alright.
Plowing ahead.
You okay?
You want.
The greatest thing about my daughter is right now,
besides everything is she gives hugs now,
like legit hugs,
right?
Like I opened the door to a room today.
She was in there talking to herself,
open the door to room shifts,
goes hi.
So I start cracking up.
I'm like hi.
And I walk over to pick her up.
I pick her up,
she grabs like around my neck and behind my neck.
She grabs like a handful of my shirt,
like I owe her money,
you know?
And then the other hand it's just sorta on my shoulder and she pulls herself in
to meet with their head right up against my head and I'm standing like,
yeah,
you kidding me.
This is the greatest thing ever.
And then after like just squeezing me for like a good five's,
the best five seconds of my life,
she then lets up and then gave me a kiss and then went and hugged me again.
It was so awesome.
Literally reenacted it to my laugh.
I was like,
this is what she did this morning.
The best part is the handful of this shirt or maybe the feeling of this decided
that face on yours.
I don't know what,
but all I can tell you this the greatest thing ever.
It's becoming a dad.
It's awesome.
You know,
I know there's the lack of sleep.
I know you.
Sex life goes out the fucking window,
but it's worth it.
It's totally fucking worth it.
Um,
all right.
Oh Geez.
Here we go.
We got,
we have one read one race in the barren landscape.
Um,
the walking dead.
That is my fucking advertisers lately.
All right.
Oh,
look who's here.
Everybody had sold zip.
Okay.
Talk about the challenge of finding great talent and how the way you went about
it just did not work.
Oh,
it was inefficient way.
Or the other day I was at a red light.
I saw about faith or sat around megaphones.
I was like,
Whoa,
there you got to say it.
I'm like,
hello related.
And I was like,
oh my God,
what dumb luck.
I just thought a bunch of talented people,
but I had to get in my car to do it.
I had to get him a truck to go do it.
A four door truck
with a bed liner,
you know,
fire,
Dole,
zip recruiter.
Or I could've just done this at home.
All right.
Ziprecruiter knew there were,
there was a smarter way.
So they built a platform that finds the right job,
candidates for you,
zip
learns,
uh,
what you're looking for identifies people with the right experience and invites
them to apply to your job.
These invitation have revolutionized how you find your next hire.
In fact,
80% of employees who post jobs on zip
get a quality candidate through the site.
It just one day and Ziprecruiter does not stop there.
They even spotlight the strongest applications you receive.
So you never miss a great match.
The right candidates are out there.
Zip Recruiter is how you find them.
Businesses of all sizes,
trust,
zip,
ah,
for hiring needs right now,
my listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free.
That's free.
Just go to zip.
[inaudible]
dot com slash bird that's ziprecruiter.com/bird the smartest way to hire.
It's the smartest way to hire.
Oh,
guess what?
So as mentioned,
as mentioned,
all freckles.
Hey there freckled face running under a tree because you don't want a sunburn
getting the shit kicked out of you.
Every outdoor recess,
whereas a teacher when you need one
is turning the big five o five Oh club.
Whatever happened to those fucking people,
they drop me too,
I think.
Um,
or maybe they're just hanging out maybe the state lane in the wage.
okay.
50 years old.
I'm turning so I have to go to the doctor.
I've decided that I'm actually going to get a doctor.
All right,
I'm going to go in there and I'd be like,
all right,
light me up but see,
take some x rays,
checkout my heart.
I'm doing all of that shit right after a half a fucking century or running
around eating fucking burgers and Bologna sandwiches and shit.
I'm going to see how much damage I've done to myself and uh,
hopefully they won't find anything and if they do,
hopefully they can fix it and dead out.
That'll be good.
I'll get a little,
uh,
you know,
get a little fresh and up here,
you know.
Got My teeth all straightened out here.
Ready to read the fucking nose.
Yeah.
Telling you right now,
Connie Chung has nothing on me that she had nice teeth.
I don't fucking remember.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
So I'm going to go in there.
I'm going to get my heart.
Liver.
Oh,
Jesus.
Stomach,
pancreas,
the whole God damn thing.
Kidneys,
the whole fucking thing.
Right?
Hey,
what was that movie?
That guy we said,
well,
they flew this space ship around inside the person's body.
MMM.
The fuck was that called?
Come on,
ed.
You're just not.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm gonna get my ears checked out too.
What is,
hey mia,
what's the name of that movie that,
that Dennis Quaid was in?
Where do you keep was flying around inside somebody's body.
Inner space.
Yeah.
I got to get that fucking procedure.
You know when you turned 50,
now they got to do that,
right?
They got to do the fucking imax up your ass.
Camera up your ass.
Inner space.
I have to do all of that shit.
It fucking,
you know,
how did this happen?
I used to be a young man,
but whatever.
I'm going to go fucking do it because,
uh,
because I get the little kid,
if I didn't have the kid,
you know,
I,
I think I just sort of drink myself to death,
you know,
you know what I would love to do if I didn't have any responsibilities when I
was seeing those people staying in there doing that America love it or leave it.
I wish it just had a lunch here and I could've just sat under a tree across the
street,
you know,
with a nice fucking adult beverage,
and I have to have a mixture though,
right case the cops came by officer,
I'm just drinking lemonade.
It's gluten free and just sit there watching the most part of me that actually
enjoyed watching them come down.
Like,
Hey,
let's go down there and piss off a bunch of liberals and they come down and um,
I just don't think that they made the problem better.
They didn't make anybody on the left and want to listen to what the fuck they
had to say,
but they were morons.
And I don't think it,
everybody on the right,
it's like that.
And I don't think everybody on the left is a fucking lunatic.
One of them here.
You leg it takes over the trying to fucking change everything that we hold dad.
Um,
who knows when they'll fuck no,
sorry,
we're a half hour in here.
I get a bunch of bull shit to do today.
Um,
dude,
my drum room is done and I can't even fucking tell you.
Well,
I'm going to tell her,
I'm going to try to tell you about how fucking awesome it is the first time in
my life.
I can play drums as loud as I want and not piss anybody off.
Okay?
If you liked me,
okay.
If it's just a hobby,
any,
and every time you go to place,
somebody tells you to shut the fuck up and you always think,
why didn't I just play the Ukulele?
Why did I have to pick this instrument?
I'm going to tell you right now,
you need to,
you need to get a drum room.
I don't give a fuck how you do it,
okay?
You know,
I was actually thinking,
you know,
if,
if this thing didn't work,
what I was going to do,
I was just going to pay somebody to literally dig a fucking hole in the ground
like a bomb shelter,
all right?
And just stick the whole fucking thing under the ground,
right?
Put some cinder blocks,
make a little room,
and you'd literally have to go down a ladder into the fucking thing.
And then of course I don't stop there.
I'm like,
well what if I had a tunnel going from the fucking house like Al Capone?
And I could just walk in like that.
You have it underneath,
you know,
the tax man can't see it,
so he can't tax your forte,
you know?
And then this is saying someday you sell a house and you don't tell anybody that
it's there.
Then one day somebody discovers it and then they're filming it and they're all
fucking excited to see all what it's going to be down there as they going to be
as safe as it can be.
A dead body.
Is there going to be a terror Adacta leg from prehistoric times?
Yeah.
They go down there and it's just some big stupid drum room,
right.
Pictures of Fred Curry and Ricky rocket,
Tommy Lee,
Nicko,
mcbrain,
all these people that I grew up watching,
Phil Rudd,
I lead the posters.
I don't have posters of any of those people.
Um,
all right,
let's do a,
and I've actually,
because of,
because of my shoulder,
which I'm telling you man,
I got it up to about 85% here and I just can't fuck it up by wailing on the
drums.
I've just been working on my feet and,
uh,
just the fucking bands and I'm getting into,
because I'm just been listened to a lot of double bass now.
And,
uh,
my younger brothers were always into like Pantera and shit and I was just like,
that's too heavy for me.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I can't believe I didn't get,
I couldn't,
you know,
I was old enough I could saw that band and I didn't.
Uh,
but I've,
she's gone fucking got like everything that they have doubt.
And I always knew Vinnie Paul was a fucking great Dharma,
but Jesus Christ,
just incredible,
incredible fucking drummer and a cowboys from hell.
And I'm broken.
Uh,
probably my two favorites.
And,
uh,
somebody,
my drum teacher told me about their live album,
that 101 proof and just how they end up broken with that little double bass
fucking riff there in the end.
It's just like,
I wanted to learn how to fucking learn how to fucking do that and I'm going to
do that in my drum room
and,
uh,
that's it.
That's what the fuck I've been doing.
I've been doing that and working on the,
uh,
that much sugar bleed song.
That's what I do.
I want to start double bass with the probably the most difficult double bass
song you could possibly have.
I'm up to about a 70 BPM,
being able to play that lick,
uh,
with playing eighth notes,
like,
like that.
Um,
it's not going that fast.
It's more like they did the digital,
digital.
Um,
and that's what I do.
Okay.
Now that you've,
you learned how fucking boring my actual life is other than when my kid gives me
a hug in the morning.
All right.
34 fucking minutes and let's see if I could fucking bullshit for another 26
minutes here.
Oh,
by the way,
uh,
they added a show.
There's the third show that I'm trying to sell up there in Vancouver.
Um,
I'm going to be up there on March 7th and March 8th,
which is going to be a,
it's going to be so much fucking fun.
I can't wait.
And I,
I,
I'm like chomping at the bit to start my road gigs,
first of all.
Uh,
you know,
I haven't worked that much this year so far.
And,
um,
do you know the bills keep coming in,
if you know what I mean?
You know,
the wife keeps spending money,
the kid needs something.
Everybody's fucking,
you know,
here's this fee for this.
Here's this fee for fucking that this is a processing fee and all that next
scene,
they just deplete your fucking five.
I have no fucking idea how anybody ever retires.
Okay?
But I understand why when you do you eat fucking dog food.
Just trying to stretch every God damn nickel you can't go.
And how long am I going to live?
How long do I have to stretch this out?
All right,
sheriff dip shit.
This is what says,
this is what somebody wrote in.
Okay.
Now that I've,
I've brought up,
you know,
talking about guns and that type of thing,
trying to keep everybody calm and relaxed and have a nice conversation or we can
somehow try to find a solution because God knows if smart people couldn't come
up a solution,
I think it's time for someone of my intellect with the podcast laying here
talking to nobody to come up with a solution.
Um,
it's just like when a celebrity says that they're going to run for president,
what I'm doing here,
this is what happens.
All right,
sheriff,
dip shit.
Bill.
I'll tell you who's a fuckup.
The sharer from that town,
you got to see this guy doing interviews.
I love how this person writes the sheriff from that town.
Like what town?
You just literally you,
you fucking had half the conversation already in your head.
Bail up.
Tell you who's a fuck up the sheriff from their fucking tap.
Okay.
You gotta see this guy doing interviews?
He talks,
oh my God,
he talks like a long island Jew who runs a deli.
Yeah.
Boy.
How dumb is this person is a great way to make a point.
Say something.
Antisemetic um,
right out of the gate that'll make people listen to,
he went on CNN is started calling for gun control to take away attention from
the fact that he had deputies push out and not engage the shooter.
Um,
all right,
I did read that there was stuff like that.
There was allegedly stuff like that going on and let me guess buddy.
You would have ran right in there,
right?
With your fucking nine millimeter,
would you?
Would you,
would you fucking pull a nine millimeter on a guy who had a fucking ar 15?
Would you fucking do,
I'm just asking you that.
Uh Huh.
And if you would that,
what do you need?
An Ar 15 four.
You're evidently not afraid.
Um,
there's a lot of people that fucking freeze up and you never know what you're
going to do in that time.
All of a sudden you start thinking of your kid.
Who knows?
It's very easy to sit there and be like,
well,
these fucking people who fucking good,
good,
good.
You know,
you know what I would've done?
Uh,
they did the same thing.
A cop who shoots an innocent black guy did in the sense that they were not ready
for the job.
They had the uniform and an idea that they were someone who could handle this.
They weren't too.
This is all a legend.
Okay?
The Sheriff Office and the Shitty FBI fucking blew it when it came to all the
warnings.
I've read that too.
I don't believe in taking every gun,
but how about not letting a delinquent kid by a fucking semiautomatic rifle
along with some stricter shit in place.
We need people who can do their fucking job.
You know,
if you take away the antisemitism,
um,
in that
I actually agree with most of that.
Yeah.
Like if,
if everything that they're saying is true,
that the people,
people like literally said this kid is threatening to shoot up a school,
he's taking pictures of themselves with guns on,
um,
and so I just can't believe yet another kid did that.
There was all these warning signs and people were still allegedly ignoring it.
If that is the case.
Um,
you know what I mean?
Is it cause it's guns?
I don't know what it is.
If somebody was on Instagram going,
you know,
I'm going to take my deck out at school.
They was standing there with told in their fucking Dick shaking it.
Right.
I mean,
how fucking long would you last year will be over
the fucking over when it mean,
what are these people have to do in a way?
Isn't that like a cry for help.
Um,
all right.
Guns are fun.
Exclamation point.
My dare is Mr. Byrd.
I grew up in rural Washington state with guns in the house and went to school
with kids who had gun racks in their trucks and went hunting after school.
It sounds like the beginning of red,
dawn.
As an adult.
I never owned a gun.
Since I don't hunt and I live in a city with policemen,
it's away.
So I feel like I can see both sides of the issue now.
There's a great fucking point with police minutes away,
provided your white there are minutes away and they will help you provide at
your way.
Um,
I'm,
I'm fucking around
before we
shut the fuck up.
I'm allowed to make jokes here.
Um,
yeah,
I get that.
I get that because that is the feeling I always understood owning a gun whenever
I did like college gigs and road gigs that were in the middle of nowhere.
Like you just drive by some little farmhouse,
some little fucking house in the middle of nowhere and you're just like this.
What is to stop anybody from just driving up that driveway,
no matter how loud you scream for help,
no one was going to hear it all right.
Anyways,
he says anyway,
the guy goes.
That being said,
I don't think the system of rules we have now is working and I think we could do
better now.
I don't think anybody can argue that
whatever system we have is not working.
And because I'm saying it's not working doesn't mean I'm saying that they now
have to fucking outlawed certain guns of whatever.
I'm just saying that,
you know,
if somebody is literally saying I'm going to shoot up a fucking school or making
threats like that while with taking pictures of themselves with guns and then
people bring that to the authorities allegedly and nothing was done,
uh,
yet this something not working.
All right.
My ideas are as follows.
One people who want to hunt can have bolt,
bolt action,
a hunting rifle.
One shot,
one kill by by Bambi.
Mommy wants some venison steaks.
All right.
You went a lot there with the reference.
Uh,
two references there.
Why Bambi?
You know,
why wouldn't you shoot the mother?
So then Bambi has no mom.
Isn't that how it's supposed to?
That's the way Disney did it.
Oh,
let's fuck fucking Hollywood liberal.
All right.
People who want to protect their homes can have shotguns for the spread,
obviously.
Well,
the one thing about the spread is like,
what if they've already grabbed your fucking kid?
You know?
I Dunno.
That's a tough fucking thing too.
Like you to shoot a gun in your house.
You want enough fire power to kill somebody,
but you don't want it to go through them through a wall and then does somebody
else that you actually like or maybe tolerating.
You know,
if you have inlaws live in with you right into the other room and then you got
to deal with that for the rest of your life.
Shod.
My mother in law,
I didn't know she's on the other five shot the fucking,
I'll tell you know something.
Your whole fucking family crazy.
I Dunno why Hawaii.
I ever married into these people.
I should have known it,
man.
You're fucking whole family had one pair of fucking shoes.
All right,
number three.
Um,
alright.
Pistols only for cops,
security guards or other people who have a credible reason that involves the
need to occasionally shoot someone.
I think that's how they do it in Australia.
Not sure too lazy to confirm.
All right.
I like the honesty of that.
Uh,
this all makes sense,
but it's also like,
uh,
what about bad people
who don't give a shit about loss?
And then everybody turns in there,
I don't know.
And you live in the middle of nowhere and you turn in your fucking gun and then
the Douche bag or wants to rob you doesn't then one.
All right.
Number three,
people who want to have fun and blow shit up can own whatever the fuck they
want,
but it has to be delivered and kept at a licensed gun range and all times,
uh,
gun rages could become the new golf course.
It's guys get some interesting ideas that show up with your buddies or the
ladies ran a fucking machine gun and have a blast.
Shoot up a bunch of paper targets dummies that look like monsters or even shoot
up some burned out cars.
It doesn't matter you having fun,
safety and responsibility in a controlled environment.
Just some ideas.
Nothing too crazy.
I hope.
Go Fuck yourself safely and responsibly.
Of course.
Uh,
I like a lot of that.
The,
the flying,
the fucking ointment in all of this is people that aren't going to comply with
it.
Um,
you know,
and then everybody is going to turn in their fucking guns and comply with all of
that except for a
my criminals or whatever.
But then it doesn't say anything that you can have a sword.
What did she booby trap you house.
I don't know.
What are the,
what are the odds that someone's going to come into your house?
I have no idea.
I don't fucking know.
I'm,
I kind of believe that now that they're out there,
I don't know how you fucking bring it back.
All this is doing,
it's just,
you know what it is.
Cause there's always like the what if and all of that because if we did have it
like that,
like you know,
you go to England,
the cops don't even have guns.
You just come up and they swarm around you and
they just sorta Columbia.
But the,
the people walking around don't really have guns
as far as I know.
I don't know.
Isn't it funny that I,
I just don't look anything up and I just start talking.
Okay.
Gun violence.
In England,
let's see what this brings up.
Gun Crime in London increases by 42% gun violence rare and UK compared to the u
s well,
it's because we're the best at everything.
If London was better at get fucking England was better at gun violence,
we'd still be under their fucking rule,
right?
All right.
Gun Crime in London increases by 42% this is a BBC news.
Oh wait.
They get,
you know,
something because of terrorism.
Now they have all the good,
the met police said there was complex social reasons why more young people are
carrying knives.
All right.
We went from Gunster knife gun crimes in London surge by 42% in the last year.
According to official statistics,
the met police,
his figures shows that there were 2,544 gun crime offenses from April 26 2016 to
April,
2017 compared to 1,793 offenses from 2015 until 2016.
All right.
So I mean,
essentially a,
you know,
that's Kinda like fucking,
what would that be?
Okay.
That's about six incidents a day.
No less than that.
Five,
four and a half.
That's pretty good for a whole city though,
right?
Knife crime also increased by 24% with 12,074 recorded offenses from 2016 2017
the med said all low crime rates were rising.
They remained at a much lower level level then five years ago.
Scotland.
Yeah.
Registered annual rises across a number of series,
offensive category,
offense,
offense categories in the past 12 months,
blah,
blah.
Uh,
okay.
All right.
I don't know what I just learned there.
I have no idea.
Oh,
and then on the side,
they have a blind MMA champion,
takes on a new takes on new fight.
The American who fled gay conversation in Africa.
Everybody just has clickbait mum's bullying campaign leads to honesty,
honesty,
app band.
Immigration dominates the Italian election.
There's a decent story breakthrough breakthrough's take time to sell
rare photographs that changed lives.
Boy.
All right.
What are we doing here?
Okay.
Uh,
let's back to whatever the fuck I was just really,
all right.
A radiologist explains why a bullet from an ar 15 is so lethal.
Was anybody questioning?
I just thought that kind of bounced off.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
Hey Bill,
love what you do and you are an amazing asset to the community.
Oh yeah.
Buttered me up.
I'm definitely going to read this.
I recently found this article from the viewpoint of a radiologist concerning the
power of an ar 15 a year.
Usually you don't hear the viewpoints from people in the medical field.
It's the viewpoint that makes this piece unique and joy.
All right,
go to the page.
Okay,
here we go.
Okay.
What I saw treating the victims from parkland should change the debate on guns.
They weren't the first mass shooting victims.
The Florida radio floater radiologist saw,
but the wounds for radically different.
As I opened the CT scan last week to read the next case,
I was baffled the history,
simply red gunshot wounds.
I had been a radiologist and one of the busiest trauma centers in the United
States for 13 years and have diagnosed thousands of handgun injuries to the
brain,
lung,
liver,
spleen,
bowel,
and vital Oregon.
Oregon's,
uh,
I thought that I knew that all that I needed to know about gunshot wounds,
but this specific pattern in injury injury on my computer screen was one that I
had only seen once before.
In a typical hand gun injury,
which I diagnosed almost daily,
a bullet leaves a laceration through an organ such as the liver to radiologists.
It appears as a linear thin gray bullet tracked through the Oregon.
There may be bleeding and some bullet fragments.
Um,
I was looking at a CT scan of one of the mass shooting victims from them.
Uh,
Marjorie Stoneham,
Douglas high school.
Oh,
I said that right.
Did I say majority earlier?
Who had been brought to the trauma center during my call shift?
The Oregon look like an overripe Mellon smashed by a sledge hammer and was
bleeding extensively.
How could a gun shot wound caused this much damage?
The reaction in the emergency room was the same.
One of the trauma surgeons opened a young victims in the operating room and
found only shreds of the Oregon
that had been hit by the bullet from an ar 15 is semiotic rifle that delivers a
devastatingly lethal high velocity bullet to the victim.
Nothing was left to repair and utterly devastating.
Nothing can be done to fix the problem.
The injury was fatal a year ago when a gunman opened fire at the Fort Lauderdale
airport with a nine millimeter semiautomatic handgun hitting 11 people in 90
seconds I was on call.
It was not until I had diagnosed the third big third of the six stress victims
who were transported to the trauma center that I realized something out of the
ordinary must've happened that gun shots,
wounds where the same low level of velocity handgun injuries that I diagnosed
every day,
only rapid succession set them apart and all six of the victims who arrived at
the hospital that they survived.
Routine handgun injuries leave entry and exit wounds and linear tracks through
the victim's body that are roughly the size of the bullet.
The bullet does not directly hit something crucial like the heart or the aorta.
The victim does not bleed to death before being transported to care at the
trauma center.
Chances are that we can save them.
The bullet is fired by an air.
15 are different.
They travel at a higher velocity and for far more lethal than routine bullets
from five from a handgun.
The damage they cause is a function of the energy they impart as they pass
through the body.
Typical air 50 bullet leaves the barrel traveling almost three times faster and
in party more than three times the energy of a typical nine millimeter bullet
from a handgun in ar 15 rifle outfitted with the magazine with 50 rounds allows
many more lethal bullets to be delivered quickly without reloading.
All right,
that's,
yeah,
that's a machine gun.
I've seen a handful of air,
15 injuries my career.
Years ago I saw one from a man shot in the back by a swat team.
The injury along the path of the bullet from the air 15 is vastly different from
a low velocity velocity handgun.
The bull.
Okay,
I get it.
MMM.
All right,
so there you go.
So there's that fucking viewpoint.
I feel like all of a sudden we're doing like an NPR show here.
Like there's nothing funny anymore.
This is all ar 15 stuff.
All right.
Here's one.
Should we move to California?
Hey,
Billy leprechaun.
My girlfriend and I are sick of the winters in Ontario,
a half the year.
It's cold,
snowy and gloomy.
My girlfriend and I fantasize about moving somewhere that's warm year round.
Should we move to California?
Is it all it's cracked up to be looking forward to seeing you in Kitchener in
March?
Um,
you know,
the grass is always great.
This sand is always brown.
Um,
okay.
You know,
uh,
I don't think California needs any body else to move here.
It's really overpopulated and there's a lot of advantages to living where you're
living.
I pen to Ontario a bunch of times.
It's God's country up there.
I know it gets cold and that type of shit,
but the fact that you live where there's a water supply,
you're not cutting.
I mean if you want to just live in a constant state of drought,
I always feel like when you live in Los Angeles,
you're like eight years ahead of the curve as far as like environmental
disasters because Los Angeles is an environmental disaster.
Never should have existed.
We had to steal water to be here and they're building all these skyscrapers and
you know,
it was kind of Nice for a minute or a little bit after those fucking banker
cons.
Cook the economy.
A bunch of people left La and now they're all being driven back into the city.
And the,
uh,
we,
we won,
we won the most congested city in the United States.
And that's saying something.
So if that's what she wanted to become a part of,
um,
San Francisco is more expensive than a New York City at this point.
I got to tell you,
it's breathtakingly beautiful state though,
when you go a little north of where I'm at and if you can appreciate the desert
desert is also very beautiful,
but uh,
to be living in it is,
is a little unsettling if you read up on it.
Um,
but you know,
I'm in the business I'm in,
so I got to fucking live out here.
I don't know what business you're in,
but,
um,
I dunno,
you know what I would do?
I would just take an awesome vacation every year with your girlfriend and just
break up the winner,
you know,
take a week and like
a weekend or like a week,
whatever the fuck you want to do and just get the fuck out of dodge.
Just break it up till it's all you really need to do because the trade off is
what you're going to be doing is now you're going to live in a climate where
it's like people come here to go on vacation to go out to like Santa Monica and
shit.
So,
um,
once you kind of live in where there's palm trees and shit,
which are not indigenous to here and I've learned,
uh,
it's not really exciting to go to a lot of places after that.
You're like,
Oh wow,
this looks like where I live.
You know,
I actually get excited by the winter.
It's weird.
I Dunno.
I can't make these decisions for you.
I don't know.
I don't fucking,
I don't pretend to know.
Um,
all right,
back to the gun shit.
And this is,
this is the last time I'm doing the gun shit,
cause I'm not sure this is not going to become the gun podcast.
I just find people's opinions really interesting here because I don't,
uh,
you know,
I don't,
I don't own guns and that type of shit.
So I find it interesting.
All right,
Bill.
I own multiple air fifteens eight,
that they are being used for mass shootings.
Contrary from what you hear,
they're best for use is for hunting mostly varmints,
Fox,
coyotes,
prairie dogs,
et cetera.
Now,
Pharma is the proper word by the way.
Um,
you sending me,
Sam ruined that word that made it made everybody who uses the word farm.
It's sound like a fucking moron.
Let me look up the exact definition here.
[inaudible]
farming a troublesome wild animal,
a troublesome and mish.
Mish,
devious person,
especially a child.
Uh,
an animal considered a past,
specifically one classified as vermin and unprotected by game law.
A varmint hunting is the practice of hunting.
I hate when they do this.
Affirming,
generally small mammals targeted as a means of pest control rather than for
food.
Varmints or may refer to a varmint hunter or describe hunting.
Okay,
so this guy is using this correctly.
Before everybody who
thinks this is you sending me Sam writing it,
they are extremely accurate and have very little recoil.
I'm able to shoot holes in quarters at a hundred yards.
Jesus,
that's fucking impressive.
They are very fun to take to a range and shoot.
With that said at gun shows and stores,
there's a really sad culture of losers that talk about tactical situations like
their real life.
John Rambo's.
Uh,
yeah,
they're basically like the fantasy football players,
you know,
acting like they know how to run a fucking football team except their gun
owners.
Uh,
they usually look like vermin.
Oh,
oh,
virgin basement dwellers.
Uh,
the thing a lot of people don't understand about the ar 15 is that it's a
modular rifle,
modular rifle.
I buy them in parts and assemble them on my own.
There's billions and billions of parts that would be available forever through
private parties to make more rifles stale.
They will never go away.
We need to get more security in schools.
There should be no way anyone should be able to walk into a school with a gun.
MMM.
It's okay.
So what then if you have a metal detector at the school,
no one could get in with the gun,
which sounds good,
but then you know,
we used to fucking,
they used to let you run around and play outside the school before you went in,
so when the kid just show up there.
All right.
A metal detector on the bus.
No,
I actually agree with that.
I think that that would be smart because there's billions and billions of parts
of avoid Google Ruger mini 14 I t a mini 14 it does the same thing.
Does it look scary?
The problem isn't the guns.
My guns will never be used for hunting humans in Minnesota where I live,
to where I live to get parts or complete a ours,
you have to go to the county sheriff and get a permit to purchase card.
They take about four weeks to get and have a pretty stringent background check.
I think it would be great if the entire country had the same process.
I think the second amendment is just as important as the first.
I wish we could all have an honest conversation about it.
I would say a calm conversation about it.
I'm the last one I'll read here.
Fucked up country a there.
Billy Strong jaws saw this on reddit.
It's a story about how a 15 year old girl with learning disabilities and severe
ADHD got in prison for throwing apples at a mailman.
I went to prison was center president,
you mean?
She continued to struggle with the offers officers through the entire process
and ended up doing five years until she hung herself after the first shitty
prison transfer.
Okay.
Transferred her to a federal prison for women.
Is this true?
This sounds fucking crazy.
They interview a girl she knew in prison who said she would talk back to the
guards because she thought it was funny the whole time she was in there.
She thought it was silly that she was in prison for throwing apples,
whatever side of the spectrum she's on.
She had the mentality the whole time she was in there.
She had that mentality a whole time.
She was in there at one point they put her in this harness thing.
That is the most ridiculous dehumanizing thing you've ever seen as well as
putting on a hockey helmet.
So she couldn't swing her head around while tied down because they didn't want
her to be a danger to yourself.
It's at the 12th 33 Ma,
I don't wanna watch this.
This sounds horrible.
Anyways,
I'm thinking,
man,
our country present system is fucked up.
Then they said that it was somewhere in Ontario and let me tell you,
Bill Canada hides behind the shitty prime minister.
Minister do good Douche who just said the right thing all the time.
Meanwhile they had mental health protocol.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Meanwhile they had mental health protocol than anything I've seen in a duck.
You mean worse?
You kind of left a word out about the US prison system that I can recall.
Fair enough.
Oh,
so Canada did all of this shit.
Let me see here.
Clicking on the link.
What we've got here,
right?
I,
I don't,
I don't want to do,
I don't want to watch this.
I don't want to watch that.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
well there we go.
So that's going to be the end of the gun debate on this fucking podcast.
Um,
I dunno,
I helping people just understand that people who live out in the air quote
middle of nowhere,
you know,
like how they're living and how they have to defend themselves as different than
you like living in a city.
Um,
okay.
You know,
and then they can also go out and hunt and they know how to hunt,
which is a,
you know,
okay.
Probably the most important skill you can have.
You know,
if the shit hits the fan,
the fact that you know how to fucking go out and get something to eat without
going to a supermarket.
I Dunno.
I think Ravin listened to all of you guys there has the,
we just have to have a better system of a,
I don't know how to do it.
How do you,
how do you make sure,
how do you make sure that crazy people don't get guns?
So then regular people who just want to enjoy them and fucking hunt or just
shoot up a bunch of shit.
Okay,
oh,
whatever.
Or they just don't trust the government,
which I don't think it's paranoid.
Okay.
Uh,
considering what has been done to our food supply,
the pharmaceutical companies,
bankers,
insurance companies,
how they just kind of are able to do whatever the fuck they want to do.
And if you really look at a lot of this shit that they've done
to this country,
it's,
it's acts of terrorism that a lot of terrorists groups would fucking jerk off
to.
Okay.
Poisoning the food supply,
uh,
you know,
making American sick,
cooking the economy,
all of that type of shit.
Uh,
putting shit in the water supply.
I mean,
that's,
those are all terrorists.
That's shit the terrorist fucking jerk off to.
Um,
so I understand why people would not trust the government at that fucking point.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what all I know is that after awhile it gets overwhelmingly depressing
and I don't know what to do about it.
And uh,
and that's it.
I'm going to go play with my kid and go play some drums.
That's it.
God bless all of you.
God bless all you responsible fucking gun owners out there.
God bless all you people out there who feel like,
yeah,
if we just got rid of all of them,
Hey God,
you know what?
God bless everyone and go fuck yourselves.
Each and every one.
Again,
those of you who have guns and those you don't,
all right,
this has been a fucking moron who to try to get to the bottom of something and
he failed miserably.
I'll check in on Thursday and I got to start watching some Bruins games.
I got to figure this out.
Okay?
Every morning I'm watching puppy dog pals and fam arena with my daughter.
Uh,
maybe I can get her,
watch her a little,
maybe just,
maybe I'll just start watching the first period.
That's better than no period,
right?
I fucking know.
All right.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.